from the time an event triggers you to
the time you're flooded with stress
hormones to the time you take a reaction
or you don't to the time the hormones
are flooded out of your body is 90
seconds you can't hold your anger that's
that over physiological response is 90
seconds so I asked her I said so Jill
what does that mean why do people stay
angry for years and she said they
regenerated every 90 seconds so so every
90 seconds you have the ability to say
your your body is saying okay here is a
buffer you need me to be is there still
a threat is should I still be stressed
and you go like yeah but my partner said
this and you get angry again and again
and again for 90 seconds and for most of
us who are so creative so you know your
partner says something hurtful on a
Friday on Saturday you say he must be
cheating on me on Sunday you say all all
the things I do for them but you know
they do they don't do for me you and you
can make it much worse we're very very
creative every 90 seconds and that's why
we stay unhappy that's why we stay angry